[Music]
hey guys the official trailer for the
seventh season provided us first look on
a lot of events that will finally take
place in Game of Thrones universe and
beside John in torment running for their
lives somewhere beyond the wall one of
the most noticeable shots from the
trailer is the upside pouring in the
Lancer stronghold and battling against
Lannister soldiers after six seasons of
preparations the nerves Targaryen will
finally arrive home and will start your
conquest of Westeros with support of her
most trusted advisors with her two
armies to redragon Sandiford three
allies while ever since the season 6
finale provided us an amazing scene of
Daenerys finally leading her forces
across the Narrow Sea
we all have been wondering about her
next move by the official trailer gave
us an answer on that question the near
soul and on Dragonstone and from there
we'll start her conquest over Westeros
besides her leading the Trekkie horde to
set an ambush on the Lancers and
tireless forces that will be heading
home upon conquering Highgarden and
defeating Tyrell Army the nurse will
also focus her intentions on the
restaurants the westerland's is one of
the Constituent regions of the Seven
Kingdoms ruled from the castle of
Casterly Rock by House Lannister as you
can see numerous shots from the official
trailer the unsullied will attack and
most probably conquer the ancestral
stronghold of House Lannister that is
located on the western coast of Westeros
if you're wondering why is it so
important for Daenerys to conquer the
Lannisters stronghold let me explain it
to you in a few sentences after an
ambush on Jaime Lannister Reynold early
and their forces despite being
outnumbered Jaime with bronze help will
manage to escape in the heat of the
battle and seek his refuge at Casterly
Rock however Jamie won't stay too long
over there but it will be more than
enough for Daenerys to figure out that
the Lannisters won't be defeated anytime
soon
if they feel a place to run and to seek
the refuge once their current positions
attacked before the final blown King's
Landing before Daenerys decides to send
all her forces on the capital and the
largest city of Seven Kingdoms the
nurse'll firstly
that Cersei and Jaime hem nowhere to run
once the King's Landing and services
rain falls the nearest will send her
army gone solid to conquer Casterly Rock
a castle which upon timings death should
have been Tyrion Lannister's but as he
has been declared guilty of regicide and
fled across the Narrow Sea Cersei
Lannister currently stands as the new
lady of Casterly Rock
you're probably wondering right now how
will the unsullied manage to conquer one
of the most formidable and well
defendant castles in all of Westeros
even with senator garyun the sister and
wife of Aegon the conquerer that helped
him in his invasion and conquest of
Westeros three centuries before the
events of the series instead to have
been grateful dead to learn Lannister
the last of the Lannister kings of the
rock road to war instead of seeking
refuge in Casterly Rock as the rock may
have it stood even dragon flame however
there are few possibilities on how the
unsullied will manage to conquer
Lannister stronghold the first
possibility includes Tyrion Lannister
and his knowledge about Casterly Rock
that might help the nearest the concrete
which actually might have been
foreshadowed throughout the series belt
Aaron's brother became the youngest
Kingsguard in history about his sister
became the Queen at 19 in the second
season of Game of Thrones Tyrion told -
where is that as soon as he reached
manhood he was put in charge of all
drains and cisterns in Casterly Rock
instead of complaining Tyrion did his
job as best as he could which we know
from his conversation with various he
said water never flowed better and all
the feces found its way to the sea it's
highly possible that while doing his job
Tyrion discovered a secret passage
inside the rock and that he will be the
one to open the gates from inside Rock
while the unsullied are waiting outside
which would actually explain why the
gates are open for the unsullied in the
official trailer beside being
foreshadowed and decide matching with
the gates being opened for the unsullied
this outcome would also measure it
landed clever and details surrounding
his character according to legend land a
clever swindled Casterly Rock from its
previous rulers using nothing but his
wits or some stories say that land found
a secret tunnel into Casterly Rock and
snuck round inside causing intrigue
between the cast released until they
killed each other it's most likely that
Tyrion will only use the secret passage
inside the rock and will open the gates
for the Unseld
to kill remaining Lancer soldiers while
this is the most possible explanation of
the unsullied conquering Casterly Rock
there are two more possibilities but not
that likely to happen second possibility
is that Tyrion won't have anything to do
with the unsullied pouring inside
Casterly Rock there's a possibility that
upon defeating the Lannisters forces in
an ambush the nurse'll simply decide
that the Lannisters don't have enough
forces to defender stronghold and we'll
send half of her forces on Casterly Rock
while it is possible the Danny would
manage to conquer Casterly Rock just as
Theon managed to conquer Winterfell
because of the lack of defending forces
the gates being wide opened is not going
favored to this theory however there's
still a third possibility which would be
Cersei setting an ambush on the nurses
forces there's a possibility that gates
are wide open then the lenser stronghold
is being poorly defended only because
it's all searched this plan search this
plan will be to ledian solid conquer
Casterly Rock which is matching with the
gates being wide open and to the lack of
defending forces Cersei will then kill
the unsullied destroyed half of the
nurses forces with wildfire which will
surely be a huge twist but is it really
accurate and is it highly possible
outcome no it's a shot of Tyrion
knocking down the Lannister lion on the
painted table at Dragonstone is
confirming the Lannisters stronghold
will be conquered in conclusion the
unsullied most likely with or even the
solitary insell will manage to conquer
Casterly Rock the nurse will conquer the
Lancer stronghold leaving Cersei without
an opportunity to seek refuge and run
over there once the near decide to
attack King's Landing this Dana's
conquest over Casterly Rock was actually
foreshadowed by Daario naharis in the
final episode of the sixth season as he
proposed Dany to lead the second sons
and take Casterly Rock so that Lancers
will have nowhere to run and as always
let me know your opinion about all of
this in the comment section down below I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
feast
[Music]